section here of my dog if I could ask
you so you know now who I am right but
I've no idea who you are it's quite loud
alright so yeah means now yeah these
mics don't seem to like me
all right so you you've seen who I am
what I'm doing what research is
currently working on and I would like to
hear who are you and what's your
interest and yeah just pumped me with
questions that you have my name is Leo I
maintain unsupervised learning package
called gentle oh right yeah sure yeah
should ask questions now I should is
this introductions to anyone yeah so I'm
Mira I basically do business
intelligence so not really related to
linguistics I'm actually quite curious
because my girlfriend studies
linguistics and it is like selecting
comprehension yeah so you're in industry
yeah yeah my name is Stephanie bootcamp
I'm looking for a customer and area of
complaint classifications complaint
custody
yeah of course some questions I am
interested in general complaint of our
specific area it's for travel that's
Ravel yeah yeah yeah right my name is an
avid camp and I'm working on for the
same company as my colleague Stefan that
comes and we found out that we have many
many use cases for for a problem that
the text data is has to be labeled
manual but you want to do it
automatically and so this is why we are
here right yeah
hello my name is on mumble now and I
studied printed media technology I made
my bachelor so I already had a bit of
quality assurance and in this thing and
I'm about to make my last ID but I don't
know exactly in what and I'm just here
to listen
yeah yeah yeah cool all right
my name is Mattie Lyra I'm a PhD student
in natural language processing right
yeah so yeah I'd like to ask like in
this whole like deep learning approach
like what kind of role do like people
who have like more domain expertise and
are more like linguists rather than like
machine learning specialist what kind of
role they play in the process right it's
important to have if you have a project
and can have a linguist on the ground
the team it would be great I would say
because it's not that we are moving now
we're moving from the traditional
feature engineering approaches to the
neural net which I'll pursue of a
feature free but there is a very part we
also need to have knowledge and what
kind of features you want to get to do
our deep max right it's not just we
always just use word embeddings and that
works and how to combine word embeddings
to represent sentences such is not
straightforward but there is research
right now that actually goes back and
combines these dense representation with
also traditional approaches it's not
said that this is completely useless you
know if you know what other kind of good
features for your that you can actually
quite easily beat the a deep mats right
so like I give you this as an example
color color mean is working on using a
dictionary since additional source in a
deep pile ostium well we typically don't
use them right but you can use them in
various ways one is to combine them with
feature spaces one is to constrain the
decoding there's this information that's
valuable and that has been made by
linguists and I really strongly
encourage you to always think
outside use the novel thanks use the
novel techniques look back at the
history what has people already been
using how can you actually brought this
to this novel methods and and linguistic
insights are very valuable yeah okay I
have another question is no one is OK so
another thing I mean this is a stupid
question but like what I saw like you
highlighted the blue dots of label data
and like expanding is right yeah but to
me like what seems most promising seeing
like the huge amount of unlabeled data
writers unsupervised learning right so
what can you tell me a little bit about
like the state of the art there and like
what's the status and do you see any
like yeah anything interesting that
might be happening right unsupervised
learning of course in using word
embeddings is also sort of very it's
always hard to really be supervised
semi-supervised unsupervised completely
apart right unsupervised learning in the
early ages like grammar induction etc
aren't so successful so those approaches
are yeah completely unsupervised
learning is not used that much except
for learning representations which is
kind of kind of say me supervised only
because you are having labels right
it's a supervised technique that you are
using them but unsupervised it's tricky
to make it work but I don't believe it
completely yeah I shouldn't give it up
totally because clustering and using
classes or inducing word categories
could also be a source of information
that could complement linguistic
resources for instance if you use
unsupervised pass or so for your model
yeah but at the moment it's really we
have the machinery which mostly relies
on supervised learning we need the
signal to be able to learn we can have
something called in between like weekly
supervised learning where you say use
some system to predict the distributions
use another like a topic distribution a
topic model that tries to predict the
distribution of the topic and then you
try to learn this additional thing
there is things in between I think
that's the right way but just playing
from scratch at the moment it's not so
clear how how to do is how to do it
successfully yeah I'm surprised learning
works or doesn't work like what do you
mean yeah so I see like using word
embeddings is a way of using unlabeled
data it's supervised learning but it's
unlabeled data so that works very well
when I say it works I put it in some
classifier yeah I usually particularly
if it wasn't work okay so it's like what
I mean yeah let's make let's make a bit
more concrete if you say again go back
to this violence and dagger which I'll
use a lot if you want to have a very
robust system then take huge amounts of
unlabeled data and use imbalance and pre
initialize your model with these
embeddings and you will see that this
model Dan gets really soon much more
robust than just trained on the original
data so that's one way of exploiting
unlabeled data which is really helpful
just did some comparison experiments for
Slovene and then we saw that really the
person there had a serious tagger with
lots of linguistic knowledge
dictionaries etc and just using a really
huge corpus an unlabeled embeddings
empty stager with both words and
characterization was getting there it
was actually more robust than the
traditional method but you need to
combine in fact you really need like
word embeddings and pretty smart pre
initialization to get this method to
work in comparison and use the right
representation right so you need some
effort to make it working yeah I hope
this answers your it's like I can never
tell if embedding works or doesn't work
like I have to split visiting the
classifier in the end like you know yeah
so and then that had place for him to
train on something so I have to use
supervised learning to evaluate yeah
right models now that's the better
doesn't work I'd understand what you
know no that's true because that's the
problem with information is in fact the
problem right
especially in bottom-dwelling Cynthia
valuate and there is a whole workshop
last year on TCL that was about
evaluating births and weddings sorry
this is actually we're so at the
workshop colleague of mine Miller's love
was giving a talk here he presented a
paper there on his PhD work which was
precisely on this matter how do you
evaluate these word embeddings you might
I given it up today about evaluating but
it's still in supervised learning about
evaluating enterprise learning today but
it's like you can say it doesn't work
because there's no metric now maybe
there's something right right you have
an opinion probably you how you evaluate
them but we typically evaluate them in
supervised cases and I hope people move
away from like this word similarity task
right which are very specific or in
general a very important part in
segregation and we need evaluation data
but then really try to find ways that
make our relations robust the possible
give you another example so if you work
on normalization we try to normalize
your text and you want to measure how
good the normalization is and then there
are test data sets that were created
especially for this purpose and even if
you do then downstream aeration like
pasta and yeah well you see you might
see big improvements will be doing
normalization but then these data set is
really biased towards having a lot of
more normalization instances in there
than you would encounter in the real
world so it's just actually not over
doing it you know you need to take care
of how you evaluate even if you have
supervised data so the best is always to
evaluate a multiple best said if
possible multiple tasks is possible but
evaluation also for the crosslink world
case how do you train I mean you can
train parcel staggers from new languages
but if you don't have tested how do you
evaluate them that's really a crucial
aspect so before a colleague of mine in
comparing geologic with it for these for
posting a proxy evaluation where we took
dictionaries and we could see that
actually trying to evaluate
on the type level just by looking the
soft metrics of the dictionary that gave
us kind of a proxy to the proper token
deliberation so you could try to find
ways to circumvent having completely
labeled data for aberration but you need
to have at least some some way in order
to compare your model to something in
order to be able to and I delete
correlative having in domain or in
language test data now I hope this
answers your question a technical
question you showed in your presentation
that you had different losses for your
20r model on different tasks and do you
have done the same network architecture
in middle yeah okay
and have you all also seen this paper
with the one model to learn them all
where they had like increases in the
performance for path tree recognition
texts to pass tree by training the same
model also on like translation tasks and
a few applies like the similar idea now
so that's a good one I've seen that
paper haven't really yet ready
I have pets on my to do this one model
for alright but you can do it in
different ways so in that what I've
shown you it's really like the heart
sharing where you train a model the same
representations at the same time with
two losses you could also do pre pre
train one of the tasks and then plug it
back in later on or there is also work
now on on trying to learn parameters
over the tasks so it's not like a hot
sharing you force the model to learn in
the same model space but you actually
double it and see how much you trust you
know like parameterize these layers to
see how much your information is shared
between different tasks there's a whole
lot of things coming out in this area
that are exciting to do and hopefully
we'll be doing soon but no not yet the
force for so far mostly the hard sharing
setup yeah
there is another paper actually which is
really my top list rate is the model all
you need is a bell all you need is a
tension or something like that
have you seen a-- that just came out
like seven days or 10 days ago and
that's the ideas i haven't read it so
please but the idea is really we don't
need even recurrent and convolutional
nets we can do much better with
feed-forward and attention mechanisms
right so let's see it's always getting
more complicated thinking going back to
more simple methods we have to see what
works to do yeah but it's exciting so
let's see yeah yeah one question
regarding multitask learning either
situation where I've nested labels
associated to text and which are
distributed very harmoniously and you
say that multitask like multitask
learning can help especially to better
classify this rare kado stroke you as
you tested this method or have you
tested that on datasets where you have
one or great where as a classification
task with for example multiple labels
which can equip procure and the tested
that whether you get better result in
the situation where those labels are
very inhuman gain easily distributed
right that's a real question so we we
didn't explore these directions yet that
fully because the like the frequency
bidding is wonder one way of using it
but we didn't analyze that and we saw
that in fact it was helping for
especially these low frequent classes in
that case but of course you could try to
combine if you have really of
fine-grained label space and the
coarse-grained label space to learn and
at the same time whether one helps or to
actually make different granularities of
your label spaces right because
sometimes going to the really huge one
with the big distribution might really
hurt you and yet you could also think
about trying to put this loss at
different stages in your models have
just shown you the traditional way of
putting
the auxilary outputs at the topmost
layer but you could also have deeper
models and try to predict there's a
paper also by yours and honors as you
see CL that tries to predict simple
tasks at lower levels in the hierarchy
so it just shares yeah right you just
Cherokee the the simple tasks I put at
the lower level and and I don't need to
make the abdomen the network do the
effort of learning both tasks on all
levels so you could it's really like
playing Lego these days right you you
have a toolbox you have lots of data you
have lots of unlabeled data when you
have also a label data from different
from different domains or different
copper which you can try to combine now
to see that whether one helps learning
the other yeah I so far use mainly
dinette for the tagging approaches
that's a it's a wrapper about CNN labs
dinette implementations at SAP I don't
know if you guys are familiar with it
have you heard it no it's it was a C C
code of neural networks from CMU and the
Euro of COBOL put of item
Binda bindings on top of it and that was
previously called CNN by CNN and now
recently developed into what's called
dinette so there's a criminal community
now developing that and the difference
to say tens of Floreana is that you have
this computational graph which you build
up on the fly and so you don't need to
recompile it and have it fixed so it's
easier like to do this hierarchical way
things or combining three lsdm you know
these more dynamic systems are very easy
with this technique but it's also being
developed so that it changes a lot so
it's a bit yeah oh yeah i don't want to
mention there's also our motives that me
now can i haven't happier to look like
chainer
would be also of computational graph
dynamic computational graphs yeah yeah
and there is so so I think tensorflow is
also having a dynamic library haven't
looked at it yet
so it's more and more coming out that
it's interesting to look at if you may
imagine I have a data set of complaint
messages and usually an Associated label
only refers to a very small part of the
document
aha Christ yeah but what are the other
possibilities to handle this problem so
that my train data is very as many many
things around that don't really fit to
the label yeah because uh yeah that's a
tricky case because that yeah not yeah
whatever yeah would be to train a model
on maybe which is very bad at the
beginning to train on that data set
using the whole document feeding feeding
that in and do the new sliding windows
yeah to elevator on and use this
pre-existing model to him
find some way to improve that Mexican
general right because the ideally she
would tell for some sentence level
annotation right this is relevant this
is not relevant you could have a filters
mechanism yeah yeah we are yeah it's you
could look at the attention leadership
effect attention mechanisms on top yeah
because in fact if you apply like a SIBO
continuous bag of words you will ever
achieve words which have lots of them
don't contribute to the task so your
final representation somewhere in the
spacious shouldn't be yeah I never seem
domain adaptation before your talk today
um you were mentioning the similarity
metrics yeah but when do you use them if
you have a specific book and you match
it to most similar DVD like I don't
understand yeah
so the idea there is okay let me phrase
go back domain efficient is actually a
field that was very active today years
ago and there were lots of algorithms
were developed and like structure
correspondence running importance
writing etc etc but then they they were
limited in the way that they were moving
from one domain to the other and he knew
what was them the goals to do to go to
the main etcetera it was like one to one
so like you are only interested to go
from books to DVDs and that's all you
care about but now since you're getting
more data we're getting more models we
want to build models that actually how
can you use this label data out there
right the resources that you already
have more effectively and if you train
so simple stupid baseline of domain
allocation is just trained on all you
have together at the same time yeah but
as you might guess that doesn't work
very well because you're mixing very
different information from different
domains together so the idea of this
domain similarity matrix is in fact hey
let's try to find instances which look
more so you have a small set of say
unlabeled data from your target domain
and you want to find what is the how are
what are similar instances from this
pool of data that I can use to retrain
your model that is better than training
at all like I have aligned
I have unlabeled linking the book I want
to find linking the DVD somehow and yeah
that's best idea in the review and and
how its labeled will be the label for my
book right right yeah that would be so
for then for that it would be the task
it the labels would the label space
would be the same but you're interested
in finding the instances that help you
more in order to find a way of hey what
is this domain thing anyway right we
typically use them by these boxes but
sometimes mixing them together is more
helpful than mixing them in the right
way than just training or not mature if
I explained it well okay so like if I
find the like like I have a fine I have
unlabeled book like lab at Lion King
example yeah and then I want to find if
it's you know a delta children's book
and I find a DVD you should called Lion
King in its initial dense section so
therefore I should put my book in the
children's section yeah you could
imagine it or you have a you have or you
have a new stream of data coming in and
you have a set of classifiers or you
have a set of data you can train your
classifier zone which classifier do you
want to take that would be like the
model selection part right versus here
hey I want to select the data that helps
me bus train this model
select the data so I don't use all the
like DVD reviews I only use some of them
yeah exactly that's the idea okay and I
similar I guess it is sad to set some
nineteen yeah yeah and okay and then the
metrics are usually quite like
unsupervised and in turn yeah exactly
they are intrinsic masters that don't
take the labels into this and that's why
hey we have only so much to use right we
use like public similarity Lda so you
have a set of metrics and then you have
to think about what other
representations that you use you know on
which you apply this matrix so you could
either just use the terms or the LDA or
diversity measures like to type token
ratio things like that and that's the
that's the main idea here but you need
more to do more in this direction okay
yeah I think I understand it better but
what what the main part of the paper
that we are having now is like I did
some early work on parsing I was also
interested K do you have these different
domains how can i select the parsing
date I train my parse room which is done
better on some New Testament and I only
used back 10 topic Lda on on this Jensen
shannon divergence so symmetrical
McLibel divergence and that helped the
best from from the space I explode like
cosine different measures different
representations but the question here
was can we used several metrics and
instead of just linearly combining them
learn on top of them how to weight them
that was the idea okay so it's some kind
of like great search you know like add
them together or like you multiply them
or you know actually yeah we'd like a
verage them it's kind of like
coherence paper we just do whatever you
can to it so here is paper I don't know
that okay but I just like when we find
out what's the best optical here is to
use they just took all the possible
context all the possible like ways to
combine them and to find what's the best
relates to mono limitations that's right
like they just did like basically like a
grid search you can imagine it
but we're just trying to find a formula
to combine them without training them
first right you do I only have a small
training set the data that you use but
then have the whole bowl of XS how do
you how can you select the best access
for your task given a small girl in the
main deficit and you just try one metric
and you train it in anything
now back then we just combined all of
them actually didn't do the whole
exploration but we since we use patient
optimization we let the learner figure
out what is the best combination that's
good thank you but if you if done
welcome yeah okay yeah okay nobody asked
for any person yeah um do you have any
you talked about your data sets which
you used to improve your the performance
of your existing models like the one
where you had the labels which were the
gaps between words in a sentence
sentence give any further data sources
you want to like exploit for you right
that's a chance right to come up with
ideas that you could potentially use no
I think there is more to be gained by
this keystroke data so this is only an
initial investigation of if there is
ability signal in this I have done some
experiments and actually but that's not
surprising how informative fist is data
from the individual and that's very
predictive right you kind of can predict
who typed so are you touching up on
sensitive issues here also at the same
time I also did some initial experiments
and trying to predict demographic
variables from such data but also I'm
very interested in doing this whole
computational social science aspect of
trying to find out more about the person
behind the text and how we can use such
information but like also not just
demographic variables but like
personality created the data set of
people who tweet about their
myers-briggs personality type and the
idea there is ok it's also again
controversial because some people say
you should use much brakes you should go
to the big five but my idea
as hey people you to really treat quite
a lot about this the types right hey I
got int J and I'm so happy I'm you know
them they put it and you can get this
data for free right it's much easier to
query for these labels and so we created
the data set for myers-briggs type and
extended that also to multiple languages
so for now we have seven languages with
between four hundred and fifteen
thousand people have such labels also
for genders so that's another area which
is interesting to see the search some
initial work that shows that say also
pasta girls are sensitive to the
demographics it's not just the main
shift but the domain shift is really
something that constitutes of different
factors but we don't know what other
sectors like
the message but also like inverter X
case the smart way of training is
follows really it's not just enough you
need to have a good a lot of data but
you need also smart ways to be able to
use it right so that's really the idea
there yeah okay it's recognizing the
person behind the text so other German
data sets available um so we have been
so now twisty couples its culture man
Twitter data for gender and personality
yeah it's think not the biggest data set
as far as I remember this is it's yeah
yeah well today that's a few have the
IDS are free we can distribute the IDs
right and then you can go and fetch the
IDs or the data from users yeah yeah
there are data sets out there there's
the Ocoee from copenhagen also has data
sets from like trust by looks or review
data that you can use okay I'm not maybe
in your case you even know something
about the users themselves um sometimes
but of course that very interesting
question for customer of course who
wants to ask exactly and that's that's
exactly what word is
now yeah but honestly this is this is
where this field is also motivated from
right you hey if you have someone on the
other chat box if I can tailor the
communication a little bit more to this
person it's you know always there's
always good sides and bad sides and
that's why also I'm very happy that our
field now starts a ethical discussion so
there were those of the years the other
workshop lasts oh this year at the ACL
about ethics in NLP oh I shouldn't move
this thing and because now we are
modeling more and more the user right
which has advantage is potentially what
also has but my message here is really
think about also labels in your case
maybe you can get a labeled information
in some distant way that you could use
for your work so you didn't ask me
anything no no last question you asked
me what you want to study so if you're
interested I don't know do you have
technical background a little bit or
yeah and you like languages yeah and you
like like techniques and it's all enter
piece maybe an area to have a look at I
can recommend that it's really a now
getting more known right and trying
getting to the stage where we can find
applications so also thanks to develop
of sciencing well yeah
yeah yeah there's really it's a huge
field it's like the hole for instance
machine translation is a whole subfield
in the field right so your dog text
classification parsing there are all
these different angles now more [ __ ] I
slash psycholinguistics enters such a
lot of things to explore ok well I'll
try to get you to the next talking
awesome yeah that's thanks IKEA once
again